corentin se préparent au grand défilé
des champions de la nba les joueurs des
walters ont été accueillis en héros à
leur arrivée samedi et dimanche les
partisans n'attendent qu'une chose la
toute première célébration du trophée
larry o'brian on voit déjà des barrières
installées le long du trajet qui
commencera dès 10 heures lundi place de
l'exposition nationale
le défilé se terminera sur l'heure du
dîner et sera suivie d'une célébration
devant l'hôtel de ville des partisans
quand déjà au centre ville pour
s'assurer une place de choix comme une
donnée aux vélies pictures because
maintenant c'est mission accomplie
l'entraîneur chef de la nouvelle équipe
championne nexus est prêt à célébrer
avec les partisans
le joueur d'oud aphteuse fred 28 est
heureux d'être de retour à la maison
après deux jours de fête avec ses
coéquipiers à las vegas il a hâte de
partager cette victoire avec les
partisans de la tannerie temps tout ce
que des bacs
le centre ville sera paralysé lundi des
centaines de milliers de partisans sont
attendus dans la ville reine pour ce
moment historique
ici mais rien médaille à radio canada
toronto